as a huge
as a fan of your shows and as a fan of
netflix
the the people there i think i can speak
for like
millions of people in hope that hardcore
history comes to netflix or if spotify
becomes the netflix of podcasting into
spotify
there's something at its best that they
bring out the
you said artists so i can say it as they
bring out the best out of the artists
they they remove some of the headache
and somehow like they they put
at their best netflix for example is
able to enforce and find the the beauty
and the power in the creations that you
make
even better than you like they don't
interfere with the creations
but they somehow it's a it's a branding
thing
probably too interfering would be that
would be a no-go for me that's right
absolutely that can't help but that's
why netflix is masterful
they they seem to not interfere with the
talent
as opposed to i could throw other people
under the bus like there's a lot of
places under the bus that could be
thrown
absolutely so i would love i know
there's probably people screaming yes
right now
in terms of hardcore history on netflix
would be awesome
you